[Music]
in not my problem news first I try to
make that my life your life motto
submitted by Pizza Queen GL oh yeah I
like pizza give me some of that I've
gotta give you these pizza sauce they
got from Detroit others I had pizza
socks from Pizza Hut DiGiorno
I don't have a pizza brand deal you
should have mixed food and socks cuz Sox
turned [ __ ] stink and it's full of
nasties and then you put food on like
something else just food most about the
socks in your mouth stupid no but then
it's associating something delicious
with something so stank and I don't
stink I'm a girl let me smell your shoes
right now it does it but she didn't want
to do it thank God I'm reading it off
too late yeah thought we will do it or
you don't love me smells like laundry
it's not everyone's feet has a little
bit of vinegar on it okay the policy is
different MGM is suing more than 1,000
victims of the Las Vegas massacre any
future lawsuits I was outraged because
what you're gonna gamble there but I was
outraged why would you give them your
money
well I win I tell you what happened I
don't even know what happened are they
actually suing them because Ocala use
went yeah the owner of MGM is who they
filed the suit against more than 1,000
Vick they owe and Mandalay Bay by the
way yeah yeah they do so am so MGM
Resorts is a big corporation that owns
the Mandalay Bay Bellagio Excalibur
lacks oil MGM sweetie said yeah which is
Aria don't own all of salt there's like
yeah there's and the rest is what
winners Harrah's owed Caesar Palace and
the other little ones and then the win
or encore win and then Las Vegas Sands
is Venetian like I don't know all of
them
you mean so yeah he's showing yeah I
don't all of it yeah well stow the
Golden Nugget used to be owned by mr.
Wynn and it transferred later by the
guys that were online billionaire
already bored
but could he tell me another story all
right so they're suing because they're
trying to avoid these victims to further
sue it's like imma sue you before you
can sue me
no no so they are suing MGM Resorts why
it's not their fault because they own
the venue where route 91 Harvest Music
Festival was held yeah so they should
have had more protection security that's
what they're saying it's someone
shooting from a [ __ ] yeah exactly they
can't but we'll make should have well
they could have they could have checked
that yeah that guy had so many guns in
his room he got all those guns and I
walked into all it's our hotel with the
fog ton of guns because he was going to
a shooting competition oh yeah check
your bags there's no like security yeah
that's that's just difficult
that's like nearly impossible airport
yeah but so every time you go to a
casino or a hotel you have to go through
TSA that's unrealistic in Bali when we
were checking to make it sound turkey to
time you go into a hotel I put your bag
for the TSA actually go do a metal
detector yeah and you put your bag
through x-ray yeah the most advanced
metal detector I've ever been through
was in the Philippines when I was there
in May so for the last like five years
I've been traveling I have a pen that's
a knife but it looks like a pen yeah if
you pull it apart it's a knife and I've
been traveling with that for so long
through so many airports and no one ever
finds it and then I went to like the
casinos Paul who is helping in the
Philippines and they make you check like
there's a lot of [ __ ] metal detectors
in the Philippines yeah and then so it
goes through and I'm just like whatever
cuz I've been through it so many times
and then though the security lady goes
penknife I'm like what if she goes you
have a penknife I'm like no I mean she
pulls it out she goes I was like
you know and I was like a [ __ ] and
she's like you can go put it back in
your car I was like what the [ __ ] dudes
oh yeah keep it yeah well I mean yeah
cuz I can just go back to the car but it
wasn't like an airport so then from that
let you take it back in your car to you
can yeah like I had a knife in my
backpack and in there like did you know
you left this in there I'm like oh [ __ ]
oh it can't be
yeah they're like we can run and put it
somewhere put in your chickens like you
know this sure but just throw it away
but yeah so that always goes in a rush
the time when I flew home from
Philippines that put it in my check-in
because I didn't want to risk yeah being
detained in a foreign country but that
was almost advanced should have ever
seen I was really upset about it I was
impressed actually so anyway so this
dude that's the lawyer representing
several victims calling a lawsuit
outrageous and bordering on an unethical
and a lot of people are just super
pissed about this and it's obviously not
a good PR mood yeah a lot of people are
doing like hashtag boycott MGM what are
they even on what grounds are they even
though I like some of their hotels they
saying that they are not responsible for
what happened they're trying to use this
like this 2002 ruling that extends the
liability protection to any company that
uses anti-terrorism technology and so
the security company that they hired for
that event was certified by the
Department of Homeland Security for
protecting against and responding to
acts of mass injury and destruction so
for them they're arguing that the
production protection extends to MGM
because they are the ones that hired
that security firm so they're saying we
were not liable for what happened right
because when people throw the event
doesn't the liability kind of change
toward the promoters and I don't know
regardless away like what grounds are is
MGM suing the victims on yeah they're
they're not trying to get money or
anything all they want the victims to do
is to drop the lawsuit against MGM so at
least that they're not even chart like
trying to go the season
kind of thing yeah because whenever
people sue they don't go for who's
actually at fault they go for the
biggest pocket yeah they always do that
yeah but so don't lawyer for the victims
and say is saying that this is really
complicated based off of the fact that
the FBI has refused to define the act as
terrorism because there's still no clear
motive as to why he did what you did so
they're not even classifying it as
terrorism which means that so what's the
difference between terrorism and a
massive shooting it's still terrorism
yes sir one is a school shooter and one
is a just the crowd shooter they're both
doing the same act but the motive is
different like one is I hate bullies or
whatever or someone bullied me and then
the other one is something like I don't
know like mentally deranged man damn
that's it's it's the same [ __ ] now cuz
glue shooters are considered terrorists
they never say it on the news though
they always like say a troubled team or
some [ __ ] like that like they never say
yeah it pulls on your heartstrings more
but when they end up reaching the papers
it's still considered a categorized as
terrorism yeah they avoid it there's
literally nothing they ever like they
don't check bags there's no like metal
detectors or anything there's it's never
happened before if people can sue
McDonald's for hot coffee being spilled
in her lap while driving they consume
actually saw what that it was really bad
though she does yeah [ __ ] out of that
but they lost people she she could sue
her I mean him yeah you could sue
anybody for anything
look there's a liability involved if so
if a burglar falls on your property they
they've like sued there's histories of
like burglars suing and winning you have
to do the Chinese way make sure they're
done would you guys feel safer if or do
you guys like it better if the all the
casino started scanning our luggage yeah
I would feel way safer like even right
before we left Turkey to get on the
plane like we already went through TSA
and everything
right before getting on the plane
actually like these swipe some stuff oh
yeah take your shoes and like they they
run the the back or they actually like
rummage through the bag I was like yes
please do this I feel way safer turkey
gets a lot of tax I don't know but
they're really like I felt really safe
when I oh yeah that's right the
Philippines has a big like anxious
occupation or their that's why they're
so like there was Mellon sectors
everywhere
I thought Vegas would be safer the bank
there's so much many yeah that casinos
had more like a house a lot of welcoming
yeah and there's so much security and
play for the money maybe they weren't
thinking about mass shootings in Vegas
you know maybe they're thinking about
robbery and like under like a lot of
conspiracy theories about it too I
haven't gone in one of the conspiracy
theory about the shooting and why there
was no motive is that there was a Saudi
prince that was on the very highest
level of that Mandalay Bay and this was
during the time a coup or some type of
internal [ __ ] was going on in Saudi
Arabia where they immediately jailed
like half of the royal family and there
was some type of power struggle and the
the conspiracy behind it is like one of
the princes that they wanted to take was
staying at the Mandalay Bay so a huge
distraction was happening to go and try
to grab this guy while the security team
of the the Prince got him to run away so
there's there's some kind of [ __ ] like
that you got to look into the details
but that's one of the conspiracy
theories yeah and then like I heard some
other conspiracy theories to know as to
like people that are like I forget if
it's pro-gun or anti-gun but one of the
groups like the opposite
gun focused Republicans oh it's one of
the political no but they're all doing
others it sounds like it's against guns
oh no it could be pro yeah a couple will
go up in sales every time there's a mass
shooting so that's why I get confused
which one it is but apparently one of
these groups are recreating all this
[ __ ] so then they could profit off of it
somehow
that's so sad every time I think of this
I think of one uh the video from dan
Bilzerian oh that guy wait he was there
yeah he was shooting or something no I
was filming himself like oh my god
there's a shooting right now and then
you went to a cop and said give me a gun
I can help because like [ __ ] away from
me yeah he would sit like marine or like
some sort of you went to Navy SEAL buddy
flunked out like twice out that's my
fella twice
like give me your gun Lee I'm in the
Navy SEAL the cops like get the [ __ ]
away from me dude like no he's like oh
I'm gonna get a gun and save people it's
like dude while he's vlogging yeah yeah
that's why I think of whenever I think
of this Wow while he has like ten girls
in bikinis following him and he's just
shirtless mm-hmm
[Music]